I had a friend introduced me to taking wheat germ, wheat germ, and wheat germ seed and
grinding it to use immediately in threads and muffins.
Could this process be okay to use wheat flour that we can buy in the store contains gluten?
But is this okay, source, and stuff processed?
Well, it all has to do with, you know, gluten tends not to be a driver of cancer.
The gluten is the most common gluten sensitivity.
So if you have antibodies to any of the glee added peptides, then this is not acceptable.
But I don't know, so how do you know?
How do you know if you have antibodies to the glee added peptides?
The only way to really do that is to run a Syrex test.
Syrex array reacts, I think would be the right one to use.
Hey, where could you learn about that?
Go on the new course product disease and autoimmune.
You will find enough information to gain yourself with autoimmune disease and antibodies to food and to peptides of different proteins.
One of the latter I didn't, if you didn't have any of these antibodies to the added peptides should be defined to use.
You may want to get some the type of grade wheat that you might want to get his cabinet.
If you can buy a cabinet flour, a cabinet is an ancient grade wheat.
I don't know if you can get a cabinet seed, you'll have to investigate that.
But do a search on cabinet flour.
This is, we've had people that have had antibodies to glee added, but they can actually eat a cabinet flour.
You have to make it as a cookbook that you can get to get your bread recipes and muffin recipes have to change just a little bit.
But we have multiple people, our family personally have high sensitivity to gluten, but they can eat cabinet flour, bread and cabinet flour and everything.
This is an ancient grade. It's got, you know, one of the theories about gluten sensitivity has to do with the fact that we processed wheat and hybridized it and to a way that it's really not the same as an ancient grade.
But if we get back to the ancient grades, it would make a big difference. So I would investigate that as well.